her injuries are extensive Shar Nails
all her chest here and here and here a
moment of childish Curiosity has changed
Jam's life
forever she picked up a land mine and it
exploded in her face sending shards into
her eyes and tearing off her hand it was
always going to be tough for her in
Yemen but the mutilations she'll now
have to cope with mean a lifetime of
hardship ahead of her it's
Miracle to start
living because we ac accepted her to be
maybe died in the operations she lost a
lot of blood and she's she was Brave
and she
lived she tells us she was with two two
friends when she spotted the
landmine jamaa may never recover from
this human rights investigators believe
what happened to her and so many others
a war crimes and those responsible
should be brought to
Justice they're still living in fear of
houie Rebel snipers picking them off one
by one in parts of Ty city this city is
probably the worst effect Ed by Yemen
Civil War in a country suffering the
world's biggest humanitarian
crisis access by journalist and
international monitors is rare and
difficult with opposing sides on this
Civil War holding different sections of
the
city Pro government Fighters backed by a
saudy coalition supported by Britain
have driven the rebels out of this part
of tires but it's still far from safe
with both sides accused of human rights
violations against civilians
the Battle Scars are all around but many
families have no choice but to keep on
living amongst these ruins and does she
feel um safe enough to live
here a little
bit we have no option she says War has
become horrifyingly normal for these
yenes she says she's going to try to fix
it up this is where her family and
children will live from now
on thethi Rebels took over several
streets in the city and they dug
themselves in by tunneling through room
to room and building to building so they
could cross across a number of different
buildings unseen by the advancing
government troops who were trying to
push them out and huge sections of the
city have just been reduced to
Rubble they can see the rebels from here
look they're just on the hill he says
sometimes they're streets away the
civilians caught in the middle live in
constant
fear Ahmed was taking out the family
rubbish when he was
shot the bullet hit me here he says and
then went straight through my arm he was
incredibly lucky the sniper was almost
certainly aiming for his heart his
grandfather shows us Ahmed in a coma in
hospital
we thought we'd lost him he says but
what could we do this is our
life but whenever the hopis retreat from
territory human rights groups claim they
leave behind hidden mines and booby
traps and keep on targeting
civilians 30 civilians on this street
alone have been killed as a result of
all the indiscriminate shelling and the
continuous sniper
fire a new centers just opened in tires
for the war wounded many of them
amputees like mother of seven hind
Yousef she stepped on a mine buried near
the entrance of her home when she went
back after the fighting and she's not
the only one mutilated in her
family the same thing happened to two of
my relatives as well she says one of
them lost both their legs another one
lost a leg like
me at the center they're making multiple
artificial limbs to cope with the
existing number of amputees there are
more than 800 already and there's an
expectation there'll be many more many
of Mines are there
still so uh we cannot we cannot say
about exact number about it but we are
thinking is lot of minds are there and
lot of people we are expecting to come
because of that Minds hundreds thousands
more than more than thousand
every single civilian like hind who's
caught up in this war is an innocent
their lives altered forever whatever the
outcome and that's what the very few
independent groups are working to change
we don't have heroes in Yemen we have
only criminals and victims and the huge
gap when it comes to Yemen is
accountability so parties to the
conflict they act as they trust impunity
and they they they act as they will
never be held account
it doesn't look like it but this is the
main government jail in ties holding
hundreds of prisoners including women
it's very close to the front line which
means it's regularly attacked by the
houthis we managed to get rare
permission to go inside many complain of
relatives just disappearing inside here
with abusers Rife and few able to
question the authorities suddenly the
Shel bped here you can see the marks
this used to be the female wing and
we're the first foreign journalist to
see this the walls are pop marked from
the most recent houthi attack here the
prison authorities say shelling from
houthi Rebels killed four female
prisoners a prison guard and a child
inside targeting any civilians is an
international War
crime Alum we were taken to see some of
the survivors including one young woman
who told us her whole family was in jail
without a trial her mother was amongst
those killed in the
shelling it was an horrific scene she
says whether it was my mother or others
they were all cut in pieces it was
Carnage the prison is filled with
inmates complaining they've been
imprisoned
unjustly the jail has been repeatedly
shelled from the nearby houie front
lines they tell us no one feels safe
here and many fear they're just waiting
to be killed
[Music]
right now few inside believe they're
getting Justice and whilst the conflict
continues they seem to be violations
upon violations of international law
Alex Crawford Sky News entires
Yemen